we're making boba making megan boba
we're making boba make and making moba
oh you gotta love that sound
hi my name is solorm and today i'm gonna
be doing something that i never thought
i'd be able to do
i'm gonna be making boba in my home my
all-time favorite place to get boba
called the laboratory
closed down due to coba 19. but they
started selling these do-it-yourself
boba kits that teach people how to make
boba on their own
i love drinking bubble tea but i hate
the fact that i don't really know much
about the cultural context of it
while the exact origin of bubble tea is
debated it's largely believed that it
originated in taiwan
in the 1980s it usually consists of some
form of tea
and tapioca balls made from cassava root
we are blessed
by the creation of this drink and i am
excited to see what this kit
has in store hi my name is elton kyung
and i am the founder of lobopatory i
wanted to bring a piece of
my experience growing up with boba to
the next generation
so we try to be original always thinking
about creating new drinks the reason we
chose a hong kong milk tea in hong kong
when it was a british colony they didn't
have access to all the dairy
and milk so they created hong kong milk
tea using
evaporated milk and condensed milk and i
think that kind of shows
us as humans being able to adapt to the
situation we're in
inside the hong kong milk tea kit you
get a little laboratory flask filled
with two ounces of black tea
can of black and white event milk black
and white condensed milk and then you
also get boba
and brown sugar and all the instructions
to cook it with
so i'm gonna be following this handy
guide that was in the kit and it tells
me step by step everything that i need
to do okay so the first thing i'm gonna
do
pretty easy is just heat six quarts of
water no six
oh shoot six cups of water it's gonna
boil
eventually
okay so now we're at the point where the
water is boiling so now the instructions
say to take the water off of heat and
add the tea leaves
this is such a cute container also
so this is gonna brew for about 20 oh
hello so this is gonna brew for about
25 minutes i probably should set a timer
hey siri set an alarm 20 minutes from
now
i set an alarm for 12 13 am yes wait
what
what time is it jesus oh my god i wish i
could swim in this
so now i'm just gonna add the evaporated
milk it looks amazing
so as i'm mixing this up the color is
becoming a light brown
cream color so i'm adding the condensed
milk to the mixture
anything left over i will lick out of
the can
i realized i forgot a step before i
added the condensed milk i was supposed
to strain out the tea leaves
so i'm gonna do that now okay not
spilling
cool okay off to the fridge boba time
let's do it okay so right now the milk
tea is in the fridge and i'm almost done
licking this can of condensed milk
luckily i don't have to actually make
the boba balls they come
already made with the kit we're just
gonna boil them
wow this is a lot easier than i thought
it was honestly all right so i'm gonna
add some water to
this pot and then bring it to a boil and
then i'll add the boba
what i think is interesting is looking
at the way it looked before
and the way it looks now two completely
very different textures
so for the next step i'm going to strain
it and add some brown sugar and honey
these are the boba bubbles can you hear
that
oh i love that sound bloop bloop bloop
and then i'm gonna add maybe like a
spoonful or two of brown sugar
okay so now i'm going to let this sit
and then i'm going to add it to the milk
tea
and see how i did individually all of
these taste the way that they should
taste
so put together it should be great so
let's do it my milk tea
that just come out of the refrigerator
then i'm gonna add a couple of spoonfuls
of boba
let's do it moment of truth
let's see how this tastes
oh oh i swallowed one hole
but this tastes bomb this tastes so bomb
i came with i made this oh my god like i
literally feel like i just postmated
this
i'm really surprised that i made this
i'm just gonna
clap for myself right now obviously i
want to keep this all to myself
but i also want to see if my friends are
going to be able to tell that i made
this myself
so i'm gonna go visit some friends
deliver them some boba
and see if they can tell that i made
this at home i don't think they can
because this is bomb
hi you match your fence
what's up i've got something for you
this looks so sketchy
oh wait i have a straw it's in a
[Laughter]
oh my package oh my god you like it
before i get a ticket i'm parked
illegally
it's actually pretty good though guess
who made it huh
you did that's right i usually get like
a vanilla
sweet something and this is sweet oh
thank you why don't you get that you
talented at things
wow wow i'm actually gonna drink the
rest of this yay
corona high five i am shocked
[Music]